did you see a little puppet up there a
little Freud puppet up there on the top
of them yes they're lazy patients hold
it when they're feeling insecure no no
no I go and I go if there's a why do you
hate you whenever you're ready
we're rolling yet so I went to this
evening once at the Paley Center it's
quite a number of years ago because
Larry Gelbart has sadly been gone for a
while
creator of the TV show mash in a billion
plays the book for funny thing happened
on the way to the forum and he and Mel
Brooks who had first met on Sid Caesar
show of shows in the 50s we're doing an
evening and a talk and then at the end
of the talk there was a Q&A as there
always is and a guy got up and he said
can you illustrate the difference
between a joke and wit and Mel Brooks
took a glass of water and poured it over
his head and he said that's a joke and
there was a long pause and the guy said
soul so what's wit then Larry Gelbart
said wit is dry it's a great line
speaking of which the structure of a
joke versus the structure of a
screenplay similar different well um can
i tamper with the question is short it a
little pleased it it's the way I'd like
to see that question is I'm looking at
the structure of a joke and then how do
you work it into a screenplay okay
because jokes jokes have to meet two
criteria to work on a screenplay they
have to either advance a story or they
have to and they have to totally come
out of character if they don't meet
those two criteria excise them they're
expendable you don't want to keep them
so that's always the rule and I've seen
writers with tears in their eyes saying
this is so funny I hate to let this go
but it's not coming out of character
it's not moving things along I
I got a dump it so you have to have
those two elements in there okay is
there a joke quota I mean I kidding
aside like do dues to be okay yeah I
don't think there is any more I mean I
hope there isn't there's two shows on
Netflix one's called the ranch and I
forget the the other one it just came on
it's with Kathy Bates and it's about a
woman who owns a pot store and they're
both like those sitcoms in the eighties
some of which I wrote for where it was
like jump talk joke joke joke joke joke
joke joke joke joke joke joke oh look
you're wearing what was the one in the
ranch that I just thought oh this is so
old-fashioned where he's wearing Uggs
that this guy who used to be a football
players wearing Uggs and the parents are
everybody's making jokes about the uggs
it has nothing to do with the story they
just are looking for jokes just shooting
in front of a live audience and someone
told us this morning that those two
shows are not doing that great on
Netflix and it doesn't surprise me it's
really old-fashioned those are rule
three jokes a page when I started and
that could be and Lots does the producer
would give you the joke one joke I had
to put in a script was a look at Barbie
Cantrell on a beach almost wearing that
bikini having nothing to do with the
story
terrible joke they're not even really a
joke Elliott's showman told us a really
nice story said I was working on Maude
and Maude was a very sophisticated
comedy where everything really jokes are
very difficult to come by because the
characters weren't very broad and he
said we had our office right across the
hall from the island wasn't on the
family and he said the characters there
was so broad that you could always get a
joke if you needed it so he said we'd be
there till 7:00 or 8:00 every night and
at five o'clock they all left and they
said if they needed a joke they would
take Archie Bunker and they'd give him a
malaprop's Oh
he'd say eat it I think I got a high Nia
I got to see a growing ecologist
and you'd have the joke because he's
just such an easy character to write
jokes for and if again you know keep
saying like my favorite sitcom is still
Big Bang and those characters are so
well drawn and the characters have so
many traits that are identifiable that
there's always a joke when you need it
there's always something about one of
the characters that's gonna fit so
whether it's a short joke or an OCD joke
or you know autism joke or a foreign
language joke
there's always something because the
characters have so many traits that you
can come out with jokes about anything
to add no I'm I'm not really a very good
joke writer I've never been I might
humor comes out of but he's a very good
joke critic when we talk
I mean jokes have never been my strength
you know a characters I've written them
and I've written but they'll usually
come out of what a character's doing is
so I wouldn't really consider them the
kind of jokes that Peters talking about
I I love jokes
I don't like joke jokes and I studied
with with with Danny Simon who said
never set up a straight line to
accommodate a punch line I and that's
what kind of annoyed me about the ranch
because that's what it did all these
wonderful actors in it and instead of
using them to develop character they
were just giving them joke after joke
after joke and it just seemed kind of
old-fashioned to me well you know when
you side much gaming to write the jokes
not a good joke you know there's an old
saying in boxing you never see the punch
that knocks you out that should work for
jokes as well but I think that you know
again to go back to where we started
with this with jokes versus wit I think
you know one of my one of my biggest
influences is an old coward no Karen did
not write jokes no coward wrote
situations that were inherently funny to
people who are on their second honeymoon
who go out on their
respective balconies in the South of
France and who do they run into but
their ex-spouses and everybody has
stolen that situation private lives was
the play and but at the time it was kind
of risque and of course what are they
gonna do they're gonna fall back in love
and fight and break up and get married a
breakup and get married and that was the
that was the premise but you can see
that really witty stuff would come out
of that but very few jokes I think he
had you know he had jokes like I'm gonna
butcher this but it was like and it cuz
one of them had been on a trip how was
Egypt very very dry you know no that's
not a joke that's what you know and and
and how are the plains of Spain very
very wet you know that kind of thing
that's not really joke writing Peters
talking about constructed jokes if you
say there is a but what's nice about
that and I'd put it a little but but the
the nice thing in the middle Cour an
example is there's a rhythm just like it
a joke there's a set up on a payoff you
know if you say very very wet and you
don't say very very dry people will
unconsciously be waiting for it and if
they don't hear it they'll be
disappointed they mean I don't know why
one of the one of the movies that works
great for me is is the first and the
second Back to the Future because
everything by the way this is what
structure is oh I'm glad I got a new
question
oh please do yeah well and this comes a
lot from my my childhood of my training
my my dad and his friends always said
all structure really is is set up and
pay off some things you set up and pay
off quickly some things you set up
halfway through a script and pay it off
later but if you set up something and
don't pay it off people are going to
notice that the film or the play was
missing something's missing
so really people for a long time I've
overcomplicated the idea of structure
really all it comes down to is setting
up and paying off if you don't do that
you don't have something properly straw
so I I give a lot of set up is all
conflict for example I set up the mother
moving in with her daughter and then I
don't pay off that something bad funny
or good funny is gonna happen I haven't
written a whole premise I haven't
written the whole they'll get along well
it's really boring right well that's the
two of them has magical anything else as
opposed to land well Charlie Peters has
always said I mean I Charlie's an old
friend of mine but he's always said this
like one of the hardest things to
explain to students Charlie taught at
USC for many years and for us briefly
but he said the hardest thing to explain
to a student is because in life we all
want to get along we don't want conflict
we want to have a nice easy but that
makes for a dull drama he gave us a
great quote in the book he said the hero
of every of every movie wants the script
end on page two right
Jack Black does not want to go to Skull
Island and find King that's the
last thing he wants to do what were you
gonna say about back to the future
oh yes short-term memory loss is a
right that everything they do in Back to
the Future everything they set up
everything and this and they went
through like 20 drafts before they shot
everything they do is paid off
everything so you feel really satisfied
when you come out of that movie you may
not know why every joke they set up is
paid off no loose ends
yeah and that's really great writing and
so and you're waiting for the sequel
because he at the end of the movie he's
like where we're going he takes the
stinking badges line from what's the
famous movie the pyramid ray Sierra
Madre roads he says what about Bette
you're backing up well you know we're
but about roses roads where we're going
we don't need no stinking rose and it's
right out of another movie and and set
you up for the you want you have to see
that sequel now
but the third one there I don't watch
that this is the Western that's not very
good
you